In Nigeria, Boko Haram insurgents kill nearly 200 in suicide attacks...
...across multiple locations over the past week.
In Greece, Finance Minister Yanis Varoufakis resigns from office...
...after the country votes against Europe's latest bailout offer.
In Ecuador, Pope Francis begins his eight-day tour...
...and expects to draw more than one million for mass.
In Austria, Iranian foreign ministers and a group of six world powers...
...gather for a final push to reach an agreement on Iran's nuclear program.
And finally from Canada, the US women's national soccer team defeats Japan 5-2,...
...becoming the first country to win three World Cup titles.